communicate using registers
okay so what's consensus in consensus
every process Pi has an input value x i
and if it doesn't crash it has to Output
a value of the y i such that the
following two properties hold first
validity but each output y i is one of
the inputs x i or X1 through x n and
moreover there's agreements and all the
output values are the same
okay so we consensus is another word for
agreement okay and wait free means that
every process terminates within a finite
number of steps no matter what the speed
of the processes is and even if other
processes crash
so um theorem says that there's no
weight free algorithm to solve consensus
amongst two or more processes of an
asynchronous system where processes
communicate using registers namely they
read or write
the proof this theorem uses a valency
argument which is a technique that was
first introduced by Fisher Lynch and
Patterson to impro to prove the
impossibility of consensus in a
asynchronous message passing system
so given an algorithm that claims to
solve consensus one first proof that it
has an initial configuration that is
bivalence this this means that there is
an execution from the configuration in
which some process output 0 and another
execution in this configuration in which
some process outputs one
in this diagram a node represents this
little figure here
okay node represents a configuration and
an edge represents a step by some
process taking the system from one
configuration to another I'm going to
use a purple note to denote the bipilla
configuration
okay well yeah okay so we have an
initial configuration that's bivalent
then one shows that for every bivalent
configuration there's a step-by-step
process that results in another bivalent
configuration
this implies that the algorithm has an
infinite execution and hence the
algorithm is not weight free
easy results a very easy proof the
details actually the details that I
haven't told you are very difficult
um case and agreements is generalization
of consensus it allows K different
values to be able to put instead of one
and in particular when K is equal to one
case at agreements is the same as
consensus so again every process is an
input value x i and if it doesn't crash
it has to Output a value y i the same
validity property it had each Yi has to
be one of the inputs and the agreement
properties at most K different values
are output
no it's also known that there is no
wheat free algorithm for solving
casehead agreement in an asynchronous
shared memory system where processes
communicate using registers the proofs
of this result are considerably more
complicated news arguments from
combinatorial topology
a natural question is whether there are
simpler proofs of this result
one more
so just to make sure I understand this
so I'm all about all the K values have
to be legal yeah so both validity what
we're saying is that all of these all of
the outputs have to be one of the input
values and we were saying that a total
of K different values can be output so
if we're talking about two set agreement
then there could be most two different
values
no this is we're not talking about
randomized alphabets here now this is
all deterministic unless I say otherwise
I'm not going to talk about anything
randomized here at all
um yes you can do you can actually there
are solutions that are randomized but
we're not going to talk about that
okay
um anyhow all right so there we have
this um this very complicated
um
groups using combinatorial topology and
the uh some of the authors here got the
girdle prize for for approving this
result so it's you know there's some
need here
um
yes they were independent they all
appeared in the same stock conference
yeah it was weird
that it's true there were three
different groups and uh and they were
slightly different proof the proofs
weren't all exactly the same but um yeah
they were all using some form of
combinatorial topology
okay so um so just before the um the
pandemic
um uh together with um one of my uh grad
students a postdoc and a couple of
colleagues I formalized this question by
defining a class of extension-based
proofs which includes be able to see
arguments
um then it proved that there's no
extension-based proofs uh proof of the
impossibility of case and agreement in
case at least two in English version
okay okay so why am I talking about
extension-based proofs of this Workshop
okay
um so this result is related to results
improved complexity this show that
certain theorems could not be obtained
in Weak formal systems for example uh
Tony Paul and Russell proof that there's
no proof of the picture hold principle
using relative Iceberg arithmetic
and in the early stages of her research
and extension-based proofs talking with
Tony about what we were doing was very
helpful
okay
you should ask
a relationship you had a relation symbol
and it's you're allowed to use it freely
like an induction so that relationship
would be like the pij but this result is
the same as the ac0 crega lower bound
it's just a different way of viewing it
it really doesn't have a whole lot to do
except for motivation that doesn't have
a lot to do they don't need to know
about that for this talk
[Music]
at all
I mean until that's really what we've
shown here is that there's no proof in
this extension base proof which is a
restricted kind of proof family that can
be used to prove this theorem that we
know is is true
okay so an extension-based proof is a
gain between a proof and an algorithm
which the proofer is trying to show is
incorrect the proofer repeatedly asks
queries and the algorithm responds to
them
the proofer's queries can be chosen
adaptively based on the responses it
gets from the algorithm now initially
the program has only reached the initial
configurations of the algorithm
the person may ask a single step query
by choosing a configuration see it's
reached and a process P that hasn't
terminated in C so that's still still
active and the algorithm responds with
what happens when P takes one step
starting from C it describes the
resulting configuration C Prime in
particular it gives a new value of the
object that P accessed P's new state
wither peace Hall weather p halts and if
so but output P output
what value PL books okay
so wins by showing you the algorithm is
incorrect
so one way the prover wins is that the
algorithm responds with with the
configuration in which the output
violate the specification of the problem
for example if the problem is two set
agreement the approver wins if more than
two different values or output and
configuration C Prime violating the
agreement property so over here
okay
um the approver also wins if some
process outputs a value in configuration
C double Prime but C double Prime was
reached from an initial configuration
which no process had that value as its
input violating validity
okay so if here the input values were 0
2 and 3 and all of them output one
though they're agreeing but they're
agreeing on a novel value so this would
get the incorrect
a chain of queries is a consecutive
sequence of single step queries where
the resulting configuration of one query
is the input configuration to the next
query in the sequence
the way the prover can mean is that the
algorithm allows the approver to
continue a chain of queries indefinitely
this shows that the algorithm violates
white freedom
um no extension proofs have one more
type of query which is called an output
query
for an output query the proofer chooses
the configuration C that is reached a
set of processes q and the possible
output value y
so we have that that triple cqi okay the
algorithm can respond with a finite
sequence of steps but processes and
queue such that starting from c one of
them outputs the value y
alternatively you can say that no such
sequence exists for example if Q is the
set of all processes then the output
query c q 0 asks whether there's an
extension there's an execution starting
from C in which the value 0 is output
likewise the output query C q1 asks
whether there's an execution starting
from C which the value 1 is output these
two queries tell the proof or whether
the configuration C is by valence okay
because there's two different an
execution of putting zero in an
execution outputting one if it gets a
positive answer to both
after making finitely many output
queries and chains of queries without
winning the approvers choose a
configuration C at first reached during
the space and then it starts the next
phase
space is the same except that the prover
can only ask queries about the
configuration that are that are
reachable from this new configuration
scene
happening until the proofer cannot start
a new phase because all the processes of
output values and terminated in the
configuration it shows we this case the
prover loses because it hasn't shown
that the algorithm is incorrect
if the broker asks an infant chain of
queries or there are an infinite number
of phases the Proverbs demonstrated that
the algorithm is not weight free
the valency argument is an example of an
extension-based proof
okay so what we did besides giving the
definition an extension-based proof is
we have proved that there is no
extension-based proof of the
impossibility of a weak free algorithm
to solve case at agreements for pay
greater than equal to two crosses for K
greater than equal to two among more
than in processes our approach was to
adaptively construct an adversarial
algorithm that wins against every prover
okay so it's sort of a flip of our
normal adversary arguments
um we later showed a similar result for
a different problem specific Ally we
prove that there's no extension-based
proof of the impossibility of a
weight-free algorithm to solve
approximate agreements at one
um more than two processes on a cycle of
like four in an asynchronous system
okay so what's that problem well let me
talk more generally about a proximate
agreement on a graph okay so here we
have graph G with versus vertex said V
initial e any each process has an input
x i which is a vertex and if it doesn't
crash most output of another vertex a
must output of vertex of G satisfying
the following two properties first every
now every other vertex lies in the
shortest path between two input vertices
in some sense you can sort of think of
this as being somewhere in the convex
Hull of the set of input vertices
okay secondly the set of outputs are
within distance one of one another so
that the set of outputs form a clique in
G for example if X1
in X2 are two inputs
um
the inputs of two processes then y1 and
Y2 are allowable
um it's a possibility for their outputs
okay and so on a cycle of length four
um essentially our graph is just a cycle
of length four a pretty trivial one and
even there we can't solve approximate
agreements seems like a very very simple
problem
okay
um recently a more General
result new who is my graduate student he
showed that there is no extension-based
proof of the impossibility of a
weight-free algorithm to solve
approximate agreement among engraves and
more than two processes on any connected
graph in asynchronous system
foreign so let me change
um let's talk about something another
aspect of this so everybody here is
familiar with redactions
um and reductions are used throughout
theoretical computer science to trans
transform with possibility results from
one problem to another
specifically if some problem T reduces
to another problem s and t is impossible
to solve and so is s
a natural question to ask is whether
reduction can be used to transform an
extension-based proof from one problem
to another specifically
T reduces to problem s and there is an
extension-based proof that t is
impossible to solve is there necessarily
an extension based proof that s is
impossible to solve
although I don't know the answer to this
question I do know something that's
pretty close together with one of my
grad students I defined a larger class
of proofs which we called augmented
extension-based proofs we showed that
many reductions can be used to transform
an augmented extension-based proof from
one problem to another
we consider reductions from problem T to
problem s which involves solving only
one instance of s but allow processes to
communicate with one another beforehand
and afterwards formally each process Pi
is given an input x i the process is
first cell problem R1 using a known
weight-free algorithm then they solve an
instance of s for each process this
input to ask is its output from R1
finally the solve problem R2 to
determine their outputs using a known we
say algorithm reach processes input to
R2 is its output for Mass these
reductions are more General than many
one reductions but less General than
during reductions
an augmented extension based proof is
like an extension-based proof except
that the proofer can ask assignment
queries instead of output queries for an
assignment query the prover chooses the
configuration C that is reached a set of
processes q and assignment F that will
put values to a subset Q Prime of these
processes
okay so in particular
um so we might say Okay f
q1 is going to Output F of q1 Q2 is
going to Output F of Q2 and
um the algorithm can respond with the
finite sequence of steps like processes
and queues such that starting from C
it reaches the configuration C Prime
um
in which
every process Qin Q Prime outputs the
value F of q i so would be what it's
assigned to do alternatively it can say
that no such sequence exists
I know what query can be simulated by a
finite set of assignment queries instead
of asking whether there's a finite
sequence of steps across the system keep
starting from C which one of them
outputs the value of y the proofer can
ask for each process in P whether
there's a finite sequence of steps for
processes Q starting from C which
process P outputs value Y and so you can
just do that for all processes PD
instead in this set
um okay so um
augmented extension base proofs are at
least as powerful as extension-based
proofs
okay so we use the same technique to
show the impossibility of key set
agreement has no augmented extension
base proof
okay
um
well what um what does
um okay so
um we were also able to prove that if um
R2 composed with s composed with R1 as a
reduction from problem T to problem s
and there's an augmented extension base
proof that t is impossible to solve then
there's augmented extension-based proof
that s is impossible to solve well what
do we know uh what does this reduction
theorem tell us well there are no
reductions from a bunch of other
problems such as K leader election and K
test and set to caseet agreement since
there is no extension augmented
extension based proof that case it
agreement is impossible to solve it
follows from the contrapository
reduction theorem that there are no
augmented extension based proofs the K
leader election and K tests Etc are
impossible to solve
okay now um the last result I wanted to
mention is that there are in many groups
um in theory of distributed computing
we're also interested in the enormous
um
um algorithms and an algorithm is
anonymous if all processes with the same
input value behave the same way in other
words what they do does not depend on
their identities or their identifiers
now
um it's known that there are no
Anonymous weight free algorithms for
solving weak symmetry breaking or
um in 2N minus two renaming among n
greater than equal to two processes in
asynchronous shared memory systems where
processes communicate using registers
um and the proof of these two results
also use combinatorial topology
okay another question that was part of
there was post one over in the original
paper but extension-based proofs is
whether these results have
extension-based proofs
and
um it's straightforward to extend our
reduction theorem to Anonymous
algorithms if there's an anonymous
reduction from problem T to problem s
and there is an augmented extension base
proof that t is impossible to solve
anonymously then there's an augmented
extension-based proof that s is
impossible to solve anonymously moreover
our proof that there is no augmented
extension based proof that key said
agreement is impossible to solve can be
easily extended to show that case that
agreement is impossible to solve
anonymously
okay since they're Anonymous redactions
for weak symmetry breaking and 2N minus
two naming to n minus one set agreement
it follows that there are no augmented
extension piece proofs and hit and I had
snow extension based proofs of the
impossibility of solving weak symmetry
braking and 2N minus two renaming
Anonymous one
here and uh say happy
questions comments
yes
you showed that something that can be
proved and this means that it's just
false there's just there's some model
where it doesn't hold so here might say
maybe there's some semantics where these
Impossible Tests can actually be solved
like maybe you run the algorithm
indefinitely and you choose some value
that occurs beautifully often or one of
these things have you thought in this
direction so I mean for um
the requirement that you have both
validity agreement with determination
are necessary for all of in order to get
the impossibility proof so if you get
rid of any of them if the problem is
um there's no problem okay so in fact I
mean if you get rid of validity then
everybody can just always put one and
never worry about it if you don't worry
about agreement everybody decides their
own input and with weight Freedom well
you know if you manage to get a dancer
fine but if not but there are randomized
algorithms for solving this for solving
things like case and agreements so
um yes
um so I'm not really sure what
directions we can take this but
um really what we're trying to say is
that I mean we would really love to have
easy proof techniques to show the
impossibility of these results and it's
just not possible so people really have
to get down
um and and look at the combinatorial
topology to be able to do that so for
example
um to show that you have a cycle of life
you can you it has actually impossible
to so to show that there's no
approximate agreement algorithm for a
cycle of length four but then you have
to use burner's lemon and a variety of
other things in order to do that and
you can't get a lovely
um simple proof of that and very
Elementary was
can you hear me
so this is a really good question
um so a lot of people here have been
thinking and talking about these
different tfnp classes in one of which
corresponds to spurner so I was
wondering if you thought maybe in the
other direction that if you added is
there like a was one of these like
complete in a sense that if you added
like Sprinter or set agreement this is a
vague question but if you added that to
your your extension-based model then
would you be able to
improve all of these other ones that
you're talking about I mean I'm thinking
I mean the model was very much like a
communication complexion
decisions like you had a notion of a
reduction to it to an S so let's stick
with that same notion like could you
show that if you could reduce to some
distributed version of spurner or set
agreement that then you know so you can
still make this decision tree that
you're that you describe but now you can
but now you can add s or S is one of
these problems because then you show
that that then you can solve the other
ones or okay I don't know I'm not really
sure I know it's a little bit vague yeah
no no no that sounds like a really
interesting direction to go like I
haven't thought about that but
I was about to ask something related to
Tony's question so uh like can you
define some search problems related to
uh refuting this uh this algorithms and
the show like it's ppad complete or some
some kind of that
it's not quite cute
anyways it seems to be not just like
it's it's
not I don't know how to make it fine
anyways I should let say things
[Music]
Google
I'm I'm not really sure I mean
yeah
I guess the the study of complexity
classes within theory of distributed
computing has been somewhat limited and
um yeah I don't know maybe there is some
Financial relation uh Financial
recommendations and like you do so it's
the company that means you really need
to use this better learner to improve
like the end of the video down
foreign
a lot of these lower bounds like uh
complexity come from playing adversary
arguments on like infinite models right
like there is no finite model therefore
which would be playing on the infinite
model so maybe that's the relationship
between these things
this is also related to the same issue
we have people looked at whether there's
any formal connection between
extension-based proofs and cost of depth
break approves for instance no because
it seems like it's possible there is
just because you have finally many
options at each stage and why am ILY
bounds and so forth
you know be happy to talk to people if
anybody is interested yeah and if there
is that would also give a Formal
Connection back to Val that arithmetic
and the official principle you mentioned
yeah
I have a comment uh not my own but um
seems relevant so I remember Carly rack
up saying once something like uh you
know we think of lower bounds as reasons
why algorithms are impossible
but there are many algorithms whose only
purpose in life is to prove that lower
bounds are impossible right and I think
you've given a lot well it's actually
it's not truly an algorithm
um it only works on the part of the um
and the part of the input that you're
restricting yourself to so it actually
is not a real algorithm but it only
looks that way as far as the proofer is
concerned so yes it is definitely in
that uh it has that flavor to it for
sure
short questions comments solutions to
problems
I see a paper
okay thank you so much
that was exciting
foreign